aussi je t'assure vraiment sûr qu'on
sent pas gouré mais non mais non plus
prendre vis a fait la course en garde la
peur ça n'a pas pu briser la wii
le pic de dior oh là l'éguille des
trépassés la serra de la mort est là
juste derrière fois un élan boat
d'anoraks du belge qui a fait la course
en solo à la semaine dernière
l'ado depuis dijon il ya des éleveurs
ouah beitia vraiment wii disposera
maintenant pas mal non c'est pas le
moment at on passe parfois dire faut en
profiter tant qu'on a des muscles chaud
et bande et il me rappelle ma femme mais
elle est où là c'est bon on l'a eu ces
mots c'est bon c'est ça la voix c'est
violer les grands espaces être jamais
l'ennui que la police militaire
non je disais ça pour détendre
l'atmosphère est bon et vous qu'est ce
que ta caisse quotas c'est pas de jets
les miquettes mais on dirait qu'il ya le
brouillard qui descend et alors qu'est
ce que ça fait puisque nous en ont
vraiment hâte en gens pensent aux défis
sazy mon grand tu as eu la peau
oui dans la vallée on a dit qu'on ce
sommet à 4 heures il est quand même
19h45 et halo 1 qui l'a faut un tas paul
pied sur braye patenôtre été mis à l'eau
hier leur y était les cas embaucher des
sherpas à déchets repris dès cher papa
c'est que me chercher ça déchire pas à
coude mais bon et sherpa y dans
l'himalaya
c'est toujours le tiers-monde cas la
meilleure pour moi je bouge plus aux
rémois la plus zen et si jamais le
brouillard givrant et aloe excès se
transforme au blizzard
ah non vous avez des blizzards d'en
juger
comment comment qu'on fait après mais
n'aura pas crever la maison michel aulas
on a des miroirs réflecteurs alors on
envoie des messages dans le soleil un
coucou un couteau un coucours bonjour la
colonne de secours
il est 7h45 ya le bal série événement où
c'est plus encore mais et alors
et alors on va vers une petite - oui sur
laquelle gammarth et fusées de détresse
d'arraisonnement bon et batum et envoie
la fusée dans dix minutes
bonjour l'hélicoptère à ses plaies ouais
derrière un nom il ya mon gamin encore
je m'écroulerais
ça tu peux lire je suis franchement
dépouillé dry à venir et non seulement
tous coups de fils ni aux joues avec ton
sec qui fait que nous vîmes pas comme ça
la future voie là non on va crever six
ans courent et moi et nous ça parte à
fond mais non tout ça monsieur ta ta ta
voulu grimper cette montagne à l'air et
tout ça pourquoi pour arnaud somé plus
anciens dragons rico carty sont communs
viendrait plus concret de piste jobs
rayonnement n'est pas plus concrète pili
ce même bateau pour la houle
regardons ça c'est pis aller qui en
descendent non tu sais quoi est-ce qu'on
peut essayer de fermer aux essais de
joie de refuge en refuge oui ça jamais
ça jamais mais le directeur du refuge il
est peiné comme un phoque les bouquetins
ils font du tout non y'a la main on va
attendre la colonne de secours n'aura
sûrement des 100 bernard avec du rhum au
tournoi anglais lors à quoi manger ou à
boire du café chaud des fêtes un buffet
montagnards gratuit j'ai une idée en
attendant les secours
oui et on va serrer un contre l'autre
pour avoir chaud mais eux uniquement
pour avoir chaud mais uniquement pour
avoir son bien sûr mais dans le fond tu
avais peut-être raison après tout oui on
aurait peut-être dû aller dans
l'himalaya en brie l'himalaya oh là là
parce que l'himalaya un accident vous
arrive au plat tout le monde est au
courant bien si on en serait resté
bloqué en haut on ont été obligés de
manger un sherpa bon survivre et puis
après ça on aurait fait un film sur nous
on aurait fait consciente du monde
plaisir et on aurait pu faire du pognon
linguère joniaux pour les ligonnès de
ski les anoraks du raid ou d'un ruisseau
aux sages-femmes prenons alors que la
diminution ou vif fr3 grenoble
quelle connerie l'alpinisme